the growing sense of urgency in Western
capital is about the need to ramp up
production of stockpiles of weapons and
ammunition is because the brutal reality
here on the ground in Ukraine is that
the war isn't ending anytime soon yes
Russia might well be running out of
state-of-the-art missiles and other
types of weapons but it still has vast
quantities of Soviet era ammunition and
armaments to Chuck into this fight the
Ukrainian troops that we've been meeting
on the ground here in eastern Ukraine
absolutely have the will still to keep
on fighting but they need to have the
means and if the West isn't putting
itself frankly on a war footing in terms
of activating those factories that have
been dormant since the end of the Cold
War then officials in Whitehall and
across Europe know full well that the
stockpiles that they have right now are
running low the cupboards then become
bare and then despite the best will in
the world to want to keep supporting
Ukraine they just won't have the ability
to do so that's why it's so urgent
because without weapons here then
Ukraine can't fight as well as it wants
to